[Music]
next brown versus the Board of Education
recalled by Toni Morrison in her new
children's book remember the journey to
school integration this event was hosted
recently by politics and prose bookstore
in Washington DC thank you my
instructions are to lean close to the
microphone so if I have not to do that
at any point and you lose my voice just
raise your hand and I'll know that you
don't hear me I'm happy to have come
here I spent a lot of years in
Washington and was here as a matter of
fact when some of these events described
in the book remember took place I was
here as an undergraduate and later as a
teacher an instructor at Howard
University every nation of course has
[Music]
Nobel times times that it wants to
remember times that they want its
population to remember as a kind of
ideal of itself
[Music]
that's a little better
these times these noble times that most
nations identify are usually Wars
conquests for land conquests for
resources they may be wars for the
deposing of a king or a czar or a
dictator they may be wars defending
oneself against an oppressor or an
invader but they are generally honorable
and bloody the best ones are honorable
the worst ones are like the honorable
ones only in the fact that they usually
swim in blood but here in this nation
fifty years ago there was a fairly
bloodless revolution I say fairly
because there was some blood and there
were instances of violence and there
were instances of torture and there were
instances of imprison
men and there was death but overall it
was a bloodless revolution I like to
think of it as a civil rights movement
that was truly civil because masses of
people thought carefully about what was
at stake and what was right rather than
what was expedient or habitual they
thought about what was elevating rather
than merely power trying to reinforce
itself that movement for it not to be
understood as one of the most noble most
mature most sweeping political changes
is inconceivable to me however it may
court the danger of not being recalled
that way and just in case it is in
serious danger of drifting into the
barely mentioned in our textbooks and in
our cultural history or in case it
suffers an untimely demise in its
narrative because its promises are as
yet incomplete before that we should
contemplate and revere that period as a
powerfully moral
treatment and of the many paths that the
whole movement took none was more
significant or singular than the Brown
versus Board of Education
there are certainly many celebrations
and memorials and books and essays and
up ed pieces all in place to mark and
analyze the events of 1954 the
culmination of years of work on the
ground and in the streets and in the
houses and in the temples and in the
churches and in the courts the
culmination being that Supreme Court
decision but as we pay tribute to those
extraordinary times and the courts the
Supreme Court's decision that signaled a
real turning point in social policy and
law it's still easy to forget one
segment of the population whose future
was the center of the cause and I'm
referring to the children not just the
ones however who walked into those
schools in the 50s but also the ones who
walk into schools now fifty years later
when I was approached to do a book for
children about Brown versus Board of
Education that's what I thought of those
two sets of children but the question
for me was how to relate those events to
young people who may have anything from
no information at all to some vague
memory of a class lesson or some adult
trying to describe the civil rights
movement to them and of course it may
have been very much like telling them
about the civil war they may feel that
distant so the question was how to make
those days alive for them in a manner
that was direct not preachy not
patronizing and not burdensome as a test
well photographs were chosen that
documented and dramatized the precursors
to the decision the decision and a
little of its aftermath but even the
most powerful images could become merely
another lesson or another collection if
they were presented with captions that
were limited to date time who weren't
aware so what really attracted me to the
project was the possibility of entering
imaginatively into the minds of the
people in the photos what they might be
thinking or feel or could have thought
or felt in language that represented the
language of the people in the
photographs that was also the language
of the readers I wanted to make the
experience as intimate as possible and
my skills are honed in narrative fiction
and dialogue so I thought that I would
bring those into play rather than a sort
of a essay type rendering of what was
going on in doing so and trying to
invent what this person in a photograph
might have been thinking to himself or
saying to another person it occurred to
me that something truly unique had
happened because I can't think of any
political movement so that's so demanded
and so required the deliberate courage
of children and their generosity
children having to behave in a manner
that was not merely to advance him or
herself but all children then and in
time to come they were at the most
vulnerable age when they were asked and
able to become involved in something big
and much much bigger than themselves
they didn't and it was hard and just
imagine it imagine yourself as I imagine
myself
eight years old 12 years old 15 years
old I'm entering a street a neighborhood
a building where I believe I am hated
well I know I am because grown-ups are
screaming at me grown-ups as well as
children are calling me names I am so
not wanted soldiers with guns have to
come along to protect me and if they
have guns maybe they need them maybe my
life is in danger
maybe somebody out there in the crowd
has a gun too and might use it but even
without those children who went to
school without National Guard's support
they entered school all alone sometimes
with a few others of their own race and
they had to spend the day there the
anxiety of entering any new school new
neighborhood
for a child is intense but to enter
under those circumstances is more than
intense trying not to be afraid
at least not showing it not misbehaving
not even getting angry not making any
mistake and try not to be heard and
trying to learn under those
circumstances waiting really waiting for
the day to end you can go home and be
with your own knowing all the while that
what you're doing is for people you will
never know
I wanted today's children to think about
that and know that that spirit that
nobility that generosity was in them too
to give up something to be brave about
something for the greater good not just
one's personal advantage where else in
their history books could they see that
imagine that kind of courage for people
their own age where else could they see
adults of all races all faiths all
classes and professions binding
themselves to each other in such a
righteous cause especially a
non-military revolution world can you
see that it still is the most startling
thing to me I am still heartened
had and I hope well I'm convinced that
young readers of remember will be
heartened to I want to read to you now
just a few words some of the passages
from the introduction to the book where
I was hoping to communicate that to to
young people you think I can do this
without my glasses
No
no risks with the eyes I had two
cataract operations you will be happy to
know the world is blindingly beautiful I
had no idea what I had lost this book is
about you even though the main event in
the story took place many years ago what
happened before it and after it is now
part of all our lives because
remembering is the minds first step
toward understanding this book is
designed to take you on a journey
through a time in American life when
there was as much hate as there was love
as much anger as there was hope as many
heroes as cowards a time when people
were overwhelmed with emotion and
children discovered new kinds of
friendships and a new kind of fear as
with any journey there is often a narrow
path to walk before you can see the wide
road ahead and sometimes there is a
closed gate between the path and the
road to enliven the trip I've imagined
the thoughts and feelings of some of the
people in the photographs chosen to help
tell this story they're all there are
children teenagers adults ordinary
people leading ordinary lives all swept
up in the events that would mark all our
lives the first people to step onto the
long path we're children and their
parents the laws in many states call Jim
Crow laws demanded separation of the
races in all
places and especially the public schools
these laws were based on the idea of
separate but equal that meant black
people could enter public areas could
use public facilities such as drinking
fountains and waiting rooms and train
stations be seeded on public
transportation go to park send movie
theaters and attend schools but not with
white people sitting apart on a bus are
not being served through the front
window of a takeout restaurant was
humiliating but nothing was more painful
than being refused a decent education no
matter how much they argued or how long
they complained black families had to
send their children to all black schools
no matter how far away many buildings
were dilapidated even dangerous
textbooks were few worn out of date
there were no supplies no after-school
programs school lunches sports equipment
underpaid teachers were overburdened
trying to make do then one day some
parents from Delaware hands in South
Carolina Virginia and Washington DC
stepped onto the path these
african-american parents formed a group
represented by lawyers for the NAACP to
sue school boards that required their
children to travel to schools miles away
from white ones closer to their homes
their case was named for one of the
parents Oliver Brown who was part of the
Kansas group the closed gates were
opened by the Supreme Court after many
lawyers and thousands of people pushed
against them on may 17 1954 the Supreme
Court justices announced a decision in
the case of Brown versus Board of
Education the decision
which said separate schools were not
equal through many states cities towns
neighborhoods principals teachers
parents and students into confusion
battles were fought to honor ignore or
overturn the decision many battles were
won some quietly some not the demand to
integrate public schools grew into a
nationwide civil rights movement to
eliminate all racist law they have the
right to vote the right to choose the
neighborhood you wanted to live in to
sit in any vacant seat in a public place
marches protests counter marches counter
protests erupted almost everywhere there
was an extraordinary time when people of
all races and all walks of life came
together when children had to be braver
than their parents when pastors priests
and rabbis left their altars to walk the
streets with strangers when soldiers
with guns were assigned to keep the
peace or to protect a young girl days
full of loud angry determined crowds and
days deep in loneliness peaceful
marchers were met with applause in some
places violence and others people were
hurt and people died students and civil
rights workers were hosed beaten jailed
strong leaders were shot and killed and
one day a bomb was thrown into a church
killing four little girls attending
Sunday School Sunday school none of that
happened to you so why offer memories
you don't have remembering can be
painful even frightening but it can also
swell your heart
and open your mind whenever I see sheets
drying on the line or smell gumbo
simmering on the stove a flood of
memories comes back to me in 1953 when I
traveled in the rural South with a group
of students we received the generation
generosity of strangers African
Americans who took us in when there were
no places for non-whites to eat or sleep
they were strangers who gave up their
own beds dressed them in brilliant white
linen smelling of mulberry and pine they
fed us from their gardens and were so
insistent on not being paid we had to
hide money in the pillow slips so they
would find it long after we were born
these were country people or city people
denied adequate education relegated to a
tiny balcony area in a movie theater
backs of buses separate water fountains
menial jobs or none like me they were
ordinary people yet although their lives
were driven by laws that said no not
here no not there no not you racial
segregation had not marked their souls
the joy I felt in 1954 when the Supreme
Court decided the Brown versus Board of
Education case was connected to those
generous strangers and even now when
dried sheets can summon up my memory of
what that decision did and what it meant
for all our futures this book is a
celebration of the power and justice of
that
decision so remember because you are
part of it the path was not entered the
gate was not opened the road was not
taken only for those brave enough to
walk in it was for you as well in every
way this is your story
I have agreed to entertain some
questions or even comment some of the
questions are long and they help me by
having some of you wrote questions down
on file cards and I've looked at them
and chosen some that I thought I could
answer
and disregarded those I couldn't but I
did notice that about a third of the
questions were really about the same
subject and I think I can read a few of
them together do you agree with Psalm
that even though it's been 50 years
since Brown versus brown a versus Board
of Education segregation has not
disappeared but has re-emerged as
resegregate a lot of public schools that
were all-white 50 years ago were slowly
evolved into all-black and what should
be done against that
I had a notion in the 50s that the work
to be done
visa the public schools and integration
was not simply integration I never went
to an integrated school
I mean I'm segregated school I live in
little town that was distinguished by
its poverty and the people in that town
were all sorts of people immigrants East
European immigrants Mexicans black
people you know all sorts and we didn't
have the money to segregate ourselves or
even the interests because this isn't as
they call it the depths of the
depression so he had something else on
our collective minds there were
different churches etc and different
social groups where there was one high
school for junior high schools and the
streets were full of people from all
sorts of places in the world I never
lived on any Street that was all of
anything so I came to a university here
in Washington when I graduated
deliberately to be among black
intellectuals so I say that because I
looked at this business a little bit
differently back in the 50s what I
thought was there should be enormous
fight and struggle for resources money
to go into those schools that were weak
and supplies and support and so on and
in tax money I thought that no child
should have the wall
or drive 10 miles away to go to a black
school when they live on a1 was closer
but I didn't think of it as either or I
thought of it as both he should have
both things
I knew that black schools undergraduate
schools graduate schools had been
splendid I had attended one that in
those days was as good a school as you
could have find anywhere and the people
who were handling the cases for
integration had all gone to those
schools those lawyers that's where they
came from the educational criteria at
those school was as high and higher than
any I have been to since and I've been
to some sense what happened to those
schools of course is the different
stories the consequence of so-called
integration
nevertheless I'd say that to say that I
am still not certain these leaders
question that now what used to be
all-white may be predominantly black and
something that used to be I don't know
whatever other ethnic group is now that
I'm not sure that we're seeing racial
segregation so much as class and money
segregation when it became possible for
african-americans to go to any school in
certain numbers in any rate or to move
into other neighborhoods they made those
choices in many instances and left
behind those who had
no economic choices so there's the
benefit and then there's the consequence
the laws the best teachers of some of
the best black schools were drained away
into other schools white schools for
better money better paid better benefits
what have you there was no residential
or black school in many instances in
other words apartheid had had created
its own blossoming professions there
were black law schools black schools of
architecture black medical schools you
know etc and black undergraduate school
black private schools etc because in
black entrepreneurs had a closed and
captured audience the black doctor the
black nutritionist Sarah and they all
lived together in one neighborhood
forced by apartheid or segregation but
the doctor lived next door to the
carpenter who lived next door to the
whatever and that was the cohesion of
the neighborhood now when that was over
it was over and it's a beautiful thing
to have more choices and of course some
of those choices left behind a different
kind of neighborhood that was bound
thereby class that's inability to move
out now some of that is changing rapidly
now I mean enterprise zones and people
moving back into neighborhoods tons and
tons of people moving away from urban
areas back into the south so it's
changing it's fluid that I think is
better than them obviously then the
forced separation but in this route to
this sort of completely diversified
world that we seem to need and desire
there are moments when you will find
certain schools that are 8090 percent
black some parts of the country there 80
90 % Latin I'm not disturbed by that
provided that all students in all
schools have a relationship or a
familiarity with other people in their
life outside of school but the question
becomes what they are taught how well
they are taught the quality of the
teaching and the morning I keep saying
the money because somehow we get this
notion that it doesn't really matter
simply because so many people were
taught in living rooms and logs but does
matter and the resources have got to go
into those schools anyway that's a very
very long sort of teacher the answer to
the question about you know is it awful
now that there's still some kind of
reintegration you know my feeling is
that all of these struggles were for
more choices rather than fewer ones I
think there should be girls schools and
I think there should be with into school
and I think there should be all sorts of
places where you go and learn to feel
comfortable but not be forced and of
course I think the major thrust of the
government and the state should be this
absolute support as its prime budgetary
requirements and interest is in the
public schools now let me see if there's
anything else that I haven't covered in
that long answer
there's one here that's a little tiny
off the wall but it sort of interests me
a little bit what advice would you give
to graduating college seniors that are
considering pursuing a career in print
journalism it's a noble calling I
suppose but you will have to change it
in many instances because of the huge
melding and corporatization of all media
including the press where the
independence and the aggravation and the
sort of provocateur role that
journalists used to play is rapidly
disappearing you know when I was a girl
and maybe some of you also journalists
you know had 8th grade 9th grade maybe
12th grade education so they thought
they were the people and they when they
said we they meant all of us and now
that they all go to graduate school and
get honorary degrees and have huge
salaries they when they say we they mean
them somebody I was listening to
something last night a man edwards has
written a book about it with all
marlborough his idol and i was amazed to
learn that he didn't go to Stanford the
way he said he didn't have a degree the
way he said he was a nice working class
boy from Madrid or Seattle or gonna what
have
and felt that he didn't have the credits
so he invented them and then when he no
longer had to I mean after the war
reporting he changed it and came clean
but in the beginning he felt in order to
be in that crowd he had to you know give
himself some false props as they say but
it was any was you know stellar stellar
a reporter who subsequently I think left
rather disappointed the way journalism
was changing but anyway if you have a
tough tough heart and a very sharp mind
just go at it and see what happens
but it's a dangerous field now for
independent thinking I mean do you think
the Supreme Court should have been more
specific in the implementation of its
order rather than all the liberabit
speed I suppose but it wasn't going to
happen so they might as well have said
all deliberate speed
that's one of the ways they got through
I mean it was a long long time it was
not overnight you know there were whole
counties who closed their schools for
years five six seven years they just
closed down to public schools and
everybody had to go somewhere else they
provided for the white children to go to
certain zoo a little black children had
to go to you know Detroit and arturito
places I mean can you believe that they
just shut them down they weren't going
to have it there's a question here and I
think a couple of other ones about the
achievement gap do you believe it's
useful breaking down success or failure
along color lines what do you believe
can be done the closest gap candor
schools do it or must come from the
community that's a very entangled you
know question and problem about the gap
you know I have a those tests
class that's what they test you know
that they don't test black people doing
better than or worse than or Asia B they
test a certain kind of culture and a
certain kind of plants I think I could
just distribute blame in a number of
places and I feel very comfortable doing
that but in my own heart of hearts I
think the changes come from parents I
really do and I hate to say that so
blatantly because I'm aware of the fact
that more and more schools are dumping
the teaching job onto parents they spend
hours and hours and hours doing over
with their children in school and it's
more and more burdensome not because
there's more and more knowledge but
because less and less is being done in
the in many of the classrooms so I'm
very mindful of that on the other hand I
get a lot of questions about how can I
help my children or my child read better
or read or why what would you suggest we
do to make children read and I always
ask them do you read do your children
see you sitting somewhere oblivious to
everything because you're reading a book
do they see you really excited about
going to a bookstore or going into the
library do you salivate or pant when you
get this book and you can't wait to get
home and read it I mean do you I mean I
say to this hypothetical parent because
you know whether they do it or not they
will see what is interesting to you and
what is fascinating
you and where your pleasure lies that
helps not just having books lying around
but by being active participants in the
process sharing stories that you read
with your children what do you think
this means will desist me etc so it's
you know you are we are as adults as
parents
I don't not sure how much what we say
matters to children but I do know that
what we do matters a great deal and they
have they are very sharp I mean their
antenna is up and shivering all the time
you know I mean they could they're like
little mind reader's it has to be
because they don't know the whole
language so they have to look at
something else
I remember once my son when he was about
four years old came into the room and
had a picture he had drawn and he said
mommy look at what I did and he showed
me this picture and I was doing
something and I said uh-huh that's
lovely
and he tore it up right in front of my
face and I said would you do that for it
and he said because you had that little
smile on your face you know that little
patronizing uh oh that's lovely and you
it was true I was trying to get rid of
him yeah yeah oh it's lovely and he
recognized it and had the whatever it
takes to tell me about it by just
ripping it up in my face then on I
realized that he knew as certainly as
much as I knew when I was a kid you know
you remember how you had to really tell
who was lying and who wasn't that sort
of thing so because they have this kind
of really sharp intelligence I think
parents can make enormous differences in
what their how their children behave and
learn in school mmm
the photographs huge boxes and of them
were sent to me some I knew that I
wanted in the book others were just sent
to me and I just picked them out and I
picked them out when I felt suddenly
that I knew probably what this guy was
thinking drinking out of that fountain
or what is that pair of women were
thinking when they were sitting at this
soda fountain you know a little string
over here and you can't go here you
can't go there
so when that appealed to me when the
photograph appealed to me that I was
able to do it and some the house itself
the editors themselves wanted me to
comment on some that I may not have
chosen more questions about the
persistence of segregation and I think I
tried to come in as clearly as I could
about the complexity of that not wanting
the necessity of doing numbers 50% this
or 50% then but at the same time wanting
choices to be available to groups this
question is a good ending because it's
about an ending and it can end this
session beloved ended with the refrain
this is not a story to pass on is
remember a story to pass on definitely
this is a story to pass on Thanks
Tony Morrison was the first black woman
to receive the Nobel Prize in Literature
she's also recipient of the Pulitzer
Prize remember is her first children's
book it's published by Houghton Mifflin
get information at Houghton Mifflin
books dot-com